yes hello welcome to this video it's a
rapid game on leeches again so what do
we get
do we get another Kings Indian with
white I did the color reppin randomly so
kind of a coincidence I guess I have
white again so let's see it doesn't
really make a big difference
she started with Bishop e2 190 f3 if you
intend to play them both sometimes
people take a little bit of a pause
after we should be too I don't I just do
it randomly whatever I play first I'm
angling for the Petrosian system anyway
so there should be 293 are the moves and
now define is the Petrosian one key
point of this line is that white has not
cancelled so in some cases I don't have
to simply and keep the King in the
center or even get it towards the Queen
side and then any black ambition on the
Kings side looks a little bit a little
bit pointless
so we'll see what he is going to play
Knight to a6 and then a couple of
options against this in this book on the
English opening by International Master
Cummings he's got castles and then let's
see 5 Quincy to what I don't know this
ready and back then when I played the
Kings engine with black I played 96
sometimes and back then which is like
fifteen 20 years ago
92 was considered a critical reply
y-term has two ideas with this move one
idea is that 95 now which is obviously
one idea of 96 is rubbish before simply
and the Black Knight has to move again
so 9 to 5 is pointers um
what black usually does in this position
is to play either c6 one sometimes move
like h5 is considered to be an idea to
make em PIH four make a g4 left slightly
this is actually one of White's ideas
and one can try to play G 4 h 4 and so
on
yeah we'll see what he's doing cannot so
maybe you can also consider just wonder
what happens if he plays like like
usually does with 85 like Bishop d7
create and he has to I mean g4 h for
something to take into account what
feels like 92 is not something that he
has on the on the way down which is a
pretty common thing to experience when
you play the Petrosian to a quick fly
there a 3s it's what you usually do
again we're ready for D 495 before white
can play on the queenside him I mean
probably G for each one go on so onward
I think if 3 was the main line back then
if I'm not mistaken I could be at
earlier it's been awhile and they
haven't even studied this from the white
perspective all that much
we can try to to simply keep the tension
something like but say Bishop to d7 yeah
we should be some certainly possible
I wonder than ever before before c8 no
back to c7 not something that looks very
dangerous the question is however before
or not is ready for some a5 if I capsule
short probably 98 and at 5s that is the
thing I know I think before looks right
85 I can go look b1 there's nothing
nothing wrong with that
you know that looks ok also those
kingside ideas on 98 f5 they sometimes
don't go so well with c6 as white um
sometimes has breakthrough ideas in the
center with c5 we should seminars trying
to complete development and maybe there
is b5 in some cases ok if I cancel my
counsel he might take on d5 and play b5
but I have night b3 in this case yeah
Knight a5 coming up yes that cannot be
back so I think I'll just cancel with
this early a 3b form
I basically have stated that I'm not
going to play any g4 h for business
okay so the asset aches pretty much has
to be played okay
whoa oxy ATM so what about 94 in this
situation there is there is there
something happening on the C file the
knight on c3 you know this is the thing
that's c4 in the highly desirable move
you've got night to be five yeah that
should be fine son that's really really
annoying them groan okay so on that's
before not be five and I still feel this
should be pretty nice for white on the
queenside if I mean I just have to get
in like 94 Bishop III and then the black
queen side is falling apart
wait 94 95 takes takes Knight takes e5
maybe should be true that's nonsense
they're the whole line doesn't doesn't
work okay I can't play a full of course
with the parrot him the night a6 no no
he doesn't really have a good square I
mean it can go to a six so then I just
go Queen b3 and I'm ready to play Knight
the five next and then that is good
Knight to c4 is my general idea 94b
should be three what you have to see is
what he did with the c6 and hating on d5
I was surprised at the capture cost if
you compare this like let's say black
does not play c6 like they as a pawn on
c7 and I have a Policy Forum and I want
to open the see farm so I play c4 c5
take on these six you recaptures I have
to prepare this move c5 no it's not so
easily played and in comparison like I
play thief
t5 and then take integrated recaptures
so we have the capture capture move and
I play him so what he did is he played
c6 and took and I recapture so I win a
temple basically in this whole procedure
and it is probably more than one tempo
so this is why I'm kind of skeptical
about him capturing on d5 in this
particular situation so here on ok 98
mmm
there are two interesting things here or
just into the interesting options 94 for
Knight a5 95 is extremely annoying all
night to b5 immediately attacking a7 and
probably just a six and half to take
it's not so good yeah this is the the
absolute standard move so f5 he will um
I mean if you don't play a 5 what are
you doing yeah the problem is one
problem is that I have Bishop to e3 Yin
and taking this pawn and then I'm
actually even ready to play a 3 I also
have 95 immediately you know 95 is there
some scenario we're sacrificing the b7
pawn could work here probably not but
we should be three is also quite strong
right five say takes e4 t b7 you play
scrimmage for something something like
that it should work
however it's tempting to get in Bishop
III and f3 and it would be really great
long-term Knight a5 rook b8 Bishop b3 is
also fantastic Wow tough decision okay
I'm really not sure what's better both
both looks extremely strong so let's
start with this one
it feels difficult to imagine that you
can give up a seven-piece then my knight
gets to some great d6 square as well for
same yeah this is recorded on May 8th
and today France we've got a national
holiday so you probably have some time
to play chess so here I am what do we
want to do usually we go be 5 and then a
5 is the idea but there is no need to
rush it so I'm going to play a three
first and I hope I can do that the black
the black attack is really really slow I
mean really slow
compared to to two other situations so
b5 and 85 I just wonder an immediate a
file is probably not good
he has b5 I would really like to play b5
okay so he what is he doing here mmm
wait it's just wait for just one second
what is he doing him he was putting this
on three in a way moving the night while
I'm taking somewhere he see c3 is
hanging but if I play let's say Queen to
b3 and I'm threatening and threatening
this yeah it's very strong threatening
to now take on b6 for example
you know that doesn't work let be five
is also pretty awful and so he has to go
back and now I'm basically granted ten p
m-- granted gifted I don't know but I
know what I play b5 and next move a five
so G form I can still take yeah let's
not move that you are particularly happy
about let's see
maybe just night to a forum where play
will be eight okay I'm taking this
easiest thing to do
okay now how to how to finish this off
night a 48 I can go look a seven then
come on okay seven it must be good
so yeah let's see
do I go h3 iam I think I do I want to do
that
one thing that I could have done already
instead of route a7 was to take on a age
group takes Knight b6 then take it exam
this one again I can consider to take
but just through cur hoop here is good
of course let's do it
I mean he cannot move the Queen because
it has to guard the the knight on a 8
the knight on f6 cannot move three
difficult for him to get some kind of
coordination and I have an immediate
idea Queen to a3 check the knight take
d6
it's pretty dreadful really I'm always a
little bit a little bit reluctant to
call it winning or anything like that in
this in these situations because black
sometimes gets this ana.k a merry
final counter-attack and then you know
you get made it it happened to me more
than once so I feel they feels very
difficult on him what does he do here
maybe just really just deform but I one
layer if he goes g4 in this position you
can actually consider play F takes G for
H takes root D 727 be sure q4 it's an
absolutely outstanding compensation oh
the bishop coming to e6 and so on I
don't I thought it doesn't feel quite
necessary just taking twice should be
good take twice with a pawn a tries to
find a move here that is still somewhat
playable but it's difficult I would
probably play G for years to get to get
something going it shouldn't be
sufficient but at least you should like
fire short ones in the game
there is no way to hold to the queenside
with passive defense that justice just
won't work
yeah this um it gives up d6 gives up d6
yeah I think I should take him why is
there something is there something going
on that I don't see you
queen bee eight maybe I've got clean 83
though it shouldn't be great if he goes
G 4 I can still take stuff and still
take him and 90 f5 is also an option in
some cases - I can make him take and
then then without this Bishop it's a
little bit more difficult for him to
attack me out to d7 Bishop I keep
forgetting that I can actually mark
those gadget is probably I should be
played okay so I'm taking this he does
actually threatened
um no Woodson wait I'm just thinking
that I'm Bishop Bishop to h4 is an idea
put up that pin looks like a pretty good
defensive move the only thing I don't
like is that it weakens here those those
squares yes the squares but it makes
perfect sense there the black queen
isn't going anywhere
yeah this is a good move I think it it
just pins this and I mean if he takes
bishop takes this is just excellent
I just probably play Knight f5 next yes
but here um I was thinking that Queen a3
is good covers both and I'm ready for
Luke to the seven also we are not sure
that rook b7 this all that fantastic
actually would yeah neither five him I
think causes more that works I don't
believe it just Bishop f6
yeah just winds up in stuff not hoop
takes us with a eight areas okay dub
wins the Queen but Tim there was there
was no defense anymore
okay so let's see this is all covered I
can just move the Queen yep there is no
nothing special going on
get a new queen soon yes could went spy
check no he doesn't
yep good game thanks for playing and so
let's go into the analysis board and
going to don't do this so that you
actually can see the engine
oh I had one mistaken I wonder what that
was
okay one mistaken we had like plus four
plus six or something like that I can
learn I can I can live with that so
let's have a look I just have to quickly
do something here so um let's let's see
here what happened on the engine it
actually gets better over time whether
like it's it it gets better wrong it
gets more precise it seems seventeen
average I think is pretty okay so anyway
92 here he goes see six a three Bishop
297 I mean I'm not a huge fan of cooling
the neurons is Hamlet it's probably
probably cook somewhat okay dissemble
castles yeah and I don't really like the
capture and d5 I mean the engine is
giving b5 as an interesting move which
is to wear is somewhat interesting like
cake cake cake and then back sacrifice
d5 is the idea next I mean I don't quite
believe in it but it's interesting we
now can enter this giving quite a pretty
decent class so we have to trade and
again I am pretty happy about this
engine wants to go a6
okay and so this is supposed to be equal
hmm
so I say rather be white him I mean this
is quite clearly better than the game
was but still okay I would see 8 a 4 is
some kind of yeah it's the only move
basically to continuing yeah may it make
sense simply I prevent any B 5 and so on
and I couldn't do this because of 95
that was an important resource otherwise
night c4 would have been pretty strong
slowly went down night c4 now it's
already pretty nice and 5 and here it
was an interesting moment Bishop e3 I
was also thinking a lot about Knight a5
it should be 3 SS and ultimately the
engine and went for this mostly because
I mean it develops a piece I know it
sounds very basic but don't move
everything like 3 times it this still
looks interesting I mean it is it is
upon here and then the engine wants to
go night aah that's not a move that
occurred to me at all
it is one way and to move the knight and
attack on c3 and ultimately it seems to
be good as well but I really like to
have a complete development so Bishop
out b6 f 3s maybe knots meander Tory but
it kind of fits form and yeah 96 in
accuracy I think this is this is really
not good yeah it takes some it costs a
lot a lot of time that a c7 now M that
that basically shows us that Tutuola
failure the engine suggests your Queen
c7 yeah that's all all nice and good but
of course why is is a lot better am I
have made huge progress on the Queen's
that already this is too weak to be
maintained forever
and there is no counter plane so I mean
the engine gives a couple of things but
it's just fantastically good here and I
mean
Luke takes a ageism move and you know it
is good for white but you don't want to
second against the night on a edge you
know this kind of situation is pretty
comfortable for white the b-pawn is very
strongly has no counter play at all a
bit g4 takes forever
I have b6 coming and it is great but
still you never use a rope to take a
night in the corner that the Train it
doesn't make sense
look a seven and I think what I do is
normally h3 engine doesn't like it I
think okay it's just plus 2 or so
instead of instead of more now it is it
is just very strong okay one can take
yeah G for starter start the counter
check and also what I was suggesting a
very member correctly I would have taken
twice with the pawn I think would have
been my choice this I would have
probably played and as mentioned it is
not enough but on the engine actually
has an idea okay Bishop f6 h form let's
prevent the hit those tonight okay so
Knight f6 G form yeah so f takes was
even stronger but this is a good
controlled move yeah it keeps everything
nicely coordinated and it's this is
always a little bit harsh in a day
engine gives mistake when you have just
4.7 and set of elastics but I can live
with those mistakes here I'm just
winning the size of material
which it takes this is gone so even that
gets a gets an inaccurate okay I hope
you enjoyed the game